efectivamente Ángela hay que decir que
al comienzo este bar donde yo me
encuentro en el centro de París era
completamente rojo pero con ese primer
gol casi de camarino comenzaron a perder
la voz a quedarse callados y ya con el
segundo con el segundo gol sintieron que
este partido estaba sentenciado y
desearon abandonar este lugar y
aparecieron los franceses que ustedes
Ven a mis espaldas que han recuperado la
confianza seguro ya ya de que podrían
ganar nuevamente esta copa del mundo por
segunda vez y segunda ocasiona
consecutivas incluso aquí hubo algunos
enfrentamientos cuando Francia marcó ese
segundo gol los marroquíes estaban muy
decepcionados algunos estaban al borde
de las lágrimas pero decían que estaba
muy contentos del camino recorrido no se
lo esperaban llegar no es cierto a una
semifinal y Bueno le desearon finalmente
suerte a Francia ustedes pueden ver este
es el ambiente la fiesta hoy se va a
extender seguramente por muchas horas
aquí en París Ángela es la emoción de
los franceses que sobre todo estaban
afuera de este recinto no habían podido
entrar estaban pegados a la ventana
mirando alguna de las pantallas que daba
el partido y cuando ya hubo ese segundo
tanto se sintió fuerte ese ese amor por
estos azules de la Francia que están
haciendo nuevamente historia al llegar a
una final de la Copa del Mundo de manera
consecutiva